foreign
[Music]
holiday of Eid marked by soldiers on the
streets of Khartoum cheered on by their
supporters
the UN has called for an immediate
ceasefire between the Sydney's Army and
the paramilitary group the rapid support
forces
but there's been no confirmation from
the Army
our beloved citizens this year we
receive it while our country is bleeding
because of this bleeding we have dead
people injuries separated families and
destroyed houses and institutions this
destruction and sound of ground fire did
not leave room for happiness that our
beloved people deserve
the rsf says it's ready to observe a
72-hour truce and blames the Army for
the continuing violence it's tweeted at
this moment when citizens are preparing
to receive the first day of idol fitter
the neighborhoods of Khartoum are waking
up to the bombings of aircrafts and
heavy artillery in a sweeping attack
that is directly targeting residential
neighborhoods
330 kilometers north of the capital in
merui people are hoping to celebrate the
end of the fasting month of Ramadan as
they usually would with large family
gatherings they too have been caught up
in the violence but the Army says it's
now in control of the airport and the
military base attached to it thank God
the country is safe the situation is
stable and the shops have reopened we
were able to bring the children to the
market for Eid clothes and hopefully we
were able to make them happy
days of fighting have left many Sudanese
desperate and Afraid tens of thousands
of people have left the capital many
have already arrived in neighboring Chad
the vast majority of these people are
women and children with huge
humanitarian needs they've LED seemingly
you know overnight with with nothing and
we know that the Urgent immediate needs
are are what you would need if you had
to flee your house
across Sudan there's a sense of unease
and fear but also of resilience and
little certainty about how things are
going to move forward Victoria gatenby
Al Jazeera